ouais je suis un Slumdog j'ai grandi dans ce
bidonville mais j'avais cette ambition et je
voulais sortir du bidonville et c'est
pourquoi je suis ici pour vous parler maintenant
[Musique]
ma mère est une prostituée mon père le  proxénète
et je viens d'un vrai euh juste je ne sais pas
ce que le monde des travailleuses du sexe et des trucs que
vous savez, c'est pourquoi je regarde le monde
d'un point de vue différent de la plupart des
gens alors que le jeune enfant
[Musique]
j'étais plus jeune tu te sens comme  les
enfants en surpoids comme aujourd'hui
vont à l'école puis j'ai commencé à
voler des oiseaux
[Musique
] J'analyserai tout le scénario de ma
vie et je suis assez dur avec moi-même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand j'étais un jeune enfant j'ai environ neuf
à dix ans j'ai rencontré Muhammad Ali et
j'ai changé toute ma vie ils m'ont donné
envie d'être un combattant comme lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je pense que plus tu es pauvre, mieux c'est
qui tu es, tu sais et c'est
pourquoi les gens du bidonville ce sont les
gars qui b  devenir le combattant que le combattant le
plus titré
[Musique]
au cours des trois dernières années, j'ai eu la
chance de réfléchir sur ma vie et de développer
mon esprit et je continuerai mon voyage
pour devenir une meilleure personne
[Musique]
j'ai vu  le combat et jusqu'à ce
qu'il se passe c'était le c'était un bon combat et j'en ai été
horrifié et je pense que le
peuple américain est est-ce que tu te sens désolé pour ce que
tu fais ouais je suis désolé pour ce que j'ai fait et
je souhaite que cela ne se soit jamais produit  me hanter pour
le reste de ma vie et je veux ma famille
et ils doivent s'en occuper mais le fait
que c'est arrivé et je suis désolé
je suis vraiment désolé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
[Musique]
ne désire plus jamais être ce gars que
j'expliquais devant moi être ce gars
ne pourrait jamais vivre comme une autre moitié de la
relation avec ma femme et mes
enfants
[Musique]
Je suis porteur Mike Tyson est le
personnage que je  'je joue moi-même c'est
jouer le personnage qui joue encore
être moi c'est assez rentable
[M  usique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]